CBS News chief Washington correspondent
Face the Nation moderated John Dickerson
is with us from Washington John good
morning morning Charlie what does this
mean for Jared Kushner because the
Washington Post who first broke the
story at CBS has confirmed and others
they say the Post says he's not been
told that he is not a target of the
investigation or a focus of the
investigation
what is he well we don't we don't know
because we don't know the full scope of
what the FBI has but we what we do know
is that he is very very close to the
president and so there he is a wonderful
source of information both on the
specific question of Russia and any
contacts and collusion with the Trump
campaign but then secondarily on this
question of efforts the president may
have taken to impede the investigation
which is one of the things being
investigated now he would have had
conversations probably with Jared
Kushner just because of his proximity so
he is a font of information even even if
he himself is not under any kind of
pressure for anything he specifically
did so they're looking from all these
contacts for information from him well
yes I mean they're looking at specific
contacts that he had and remember also
its importance his contacts came after
the election which is quite different
than Michael Flynn who was having
contacts with the Russian ambassador
before the election took place so that's
one important distinction but he is just
in the inner circle and any time in an
investigation you want to talk to people
on the inner circle to get information
if nothing else the just as they
returned from a Memorial Day weekend CBS
News is reporting to that the president
is considering shaking up his
communications team having a team inside
the White House and outside of the White
House to do messaging to combat these
probes where does that place them in
terms of the focus of what this White
House wants to do well this isn't the
first president who thinks that the way
things are going is really just a
messaging problem and not anything else
this is a very familiar thing with
presidents but the challenge here that
is new with this president that is
different than previous ones is that it
is often the words from the President
himself that undermines the messaging
capability of the White House not only
the staff at the White House but the
vice president is
National Security Adviser and so that is
a problem that cannot be fixed with more
hiring secondarily there is a structural
issue at the White House which is that
you have many different channels of
control and information and people doing
what they call end runs in the in the
structure of white houses and that can't
be fixed by a new messaging team either
it has to be something that's fixed by
empowering one person who's not the
President and having straight lines of
communication and those are all big
challenges John over in Europe the
president berated NATO members for not
paying their fair share of Defense
beyond that it was a series of awkward
and unusual interactions how do you
grade that leg of the president's
foreign trip and yes well it depends if
it's on stagecraft there are so there
were a few bumpy moments but you know
when when I spoke to former Secretary of
Defense Robert Gates he said you know
the president's position on NATO is
getting NATO members to focus more on
their contributions to NATO than
previous presidents all of whom have
tried to get the same thing to happen
and so the tough language that the
president uses that irritates NATO
members may actually be getting some of
the results that he wants and let's talk
about Montana the the special election
the sexual election they're not a big
surprise that he ended up a winning but
was it a lost opportunity for the
Democrats well it was a won that
Democrats thought they could have a run
at you know there this is a this was a
Republican seat to pick up and and you
know this was one in which the early
vote was in before the body-slamming
incident so Republicans would have liked
to have had it but the thing that will
really this is all really about what's
going to happen in 2018 and we always
over read the special election so this
one was crazy for all of its own reasons
but the the challenge for Republicans is
where their president's approval rating
is when we get closer to the 2018 races
John Dickerson in Washington John thanks